bro you're the funniest cat i've met i'm
not going that's certified just then
you're the funniest cat up there going
um guys wagon
uh welcome back um as
always we hope you have a good time
jump on the patreon for that uncensored
unfiltered
original content yeah man it's only
three pounds a month tempe a day you
know the vibes
it's easy money easy it's just money
better content well it's not better
content it's just different content and
more
you know like you said unfiltered
uncensored the raw stuff
yeah the good stuff the foundations that
we started up on exactly
exactly before we start being a bit more
careful
before we were scared about getting
cancelled this is all the kind of stuff
that's on patreon exactly and like we
said before as well we said last week
um from january i'm going to be doing
two apps a month on patreon so added
incentive to
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's six episodes
a month as opposed to four
yeah we've got some ideas i'm gonna try
and make it a little bit more
interactive as well
a few lives uh a few q a's yeah on
patreon as well
yeah so yeah um but yeah anyway
uh jump in yeah man so i've got a fun
factor today which was actually sent to
me by a fan which is very dope
gang um so yeah it was gonna send me
fine i'm pretty cool about that um so
she said okay so i'm watching the new
podcast and i got a new fact for you
um she said the genital structures of
the female spotted hyena
win them the distinction of being able
to being the only
how do you say this one mammalian
like like a a mammal species
okay so the so it's basically a female
mammal how do you spell it
so mammal but with i a n at the end
mammalian
mammalian mammal is it having mammal
mammalian yeah mammalian i guess
the only mammalian yeah mammalian the
only mam i've never used that word in my
entire life i didn't know existed
anyway yeah so the genital structure of
female spotted hyenas win them the
distinction of being the only
mammalian mammalian female i was going
to say mammalian again
jesus the only mammalian females
to copulate urinate and give birth
through the penile light canal
it's even possible for females to
achieve erections
to be fair i actually
i'm sure i've heard before actually
that hyenas give birth through their
like pee hole
and i think a lot a lot of female hyenas
die in childbirth
i think that's really common sounds
about right yeah actually i'm sure
that's the fact that a lot a higher
percentage of female hyenas died during
childbirth
i'm sure that's the case
googs that i'm doing right now during
childhood
yeah spotted hyenas have a painful and
risky birthing process the birth canal
vagina is only about
one inch across oh my god and
consequently many hyenas
many hyena babies do not survive
suffocation is
a frequent occurrence for the cubs as is
death for first-time hyena mothers
yeah gee that is hyenas go through it
savage just getting
into this world is long for a hyena no
wonder they're out here just yamming off
bro they're just vex they're just vexed
from jungle i i'm
sure this is also a fact i'm pretty sure
that sharks only give birth to one
i'm pretty sure sharks give birth
like mammals i think i could be getting
this completely wrong i don't think
sharks lay eggs
even though they're a fish this could be
way off so no one get mad at me in the
comments if i get this wrong
but i don't think sharks lay eggs i
actually think
they give birth to baby sharks and i
think
only one shark comes out and it eats
all the other siblings
before it's born i think that's a thing
what the [ __ ]
i think they i think they do
this video no no i don't think they do
lay eggs
i don't think they do legs but i don't
i'm not i've not looked into detail
about them yamming up
their siblings post birth yeah man this
is why i can't wait till we can afford a
producer to just google stuff
yeah right so shark
shark it could be a specific like you
said it was a specific type of shark
that
shark pups in womb that just popped up
shark pups in womb shark embryos
cannibalized their
litter mates in the womb with the
largest embryo
eating all but one of its siblings oh it
leaves one
for some reason yeah bro
it's part of the struggle for paternity
in utero where babies of different
fathers compete so there can be babies
from different fathers all up in the
uterus
and they just fight and eat each other
and then two come out
babies of different fathers imagine that
happening to a human
bro imagine a woman just getting bam bam
bam
three different man three different utes
and they used just scrapping scrapping
in there
well and that's because i'm pretty sure
um researchers have shown that like
the pups when they're born they've got
like scratches all over
them from just scrapping in there
yes just fighting in the womb
what imagine being the mum knowing that
that my kids are just eating each other
in there no that's tall man
and then no wonder they're savages spam
yeah yeah makes sense
no wonder these sharks are savage they
don't care anymore they've been through
it
i i was eating my siblings before i was
born
what can you bring to mind what you i'm
about i'm a hardened vet
what can you say to me i've seen
everything
everything i've not been about for that
long before i was even born
what can you do to me sharks are savage
that makes me feel sick
yeah man the what like we said in the
previous episodes the wild is well and
truly the wild one bro
i couldn't see these things i couldn't
be an animal being an animal was long i
was thinking about it again the other
day yeah
i watched i watched another documentary
i've watched a lot obviously you said
before i watched a lot of like david
attenborough utc like wildlife
documentaries
and i just i just couldn't
like obviously we as humans
we cook our food and blah blah we we
have a bit of season oh yeah a bit of
season and these men
eat raw function fam they eat the organs
they eat fam
it's just pure hemoglobin everything's
that's it bro
oh that's what it is let's say that i
finally watched the octopus teacher what
do you think
tell us i didn't watch all of it i
watched most of it okay
and um it was cool okay the guy
was a bit weird like as i'm watching it
i can as i'm watching it like and it's
developing in the scenes and stuff like
that
i can literally imagine him telling a
story and at the end of every story that
i tell him i can imagine him being like
and then we had sex do you know what i
mean because i said to you
he he falls in love with that but he
doesn't you know he sounded weird
literally is so
enamored with this octopus yes at any
moment i can imagine being like
and then i [ __ ] it and it was
fantastic
that's what i can imagine saying he was
involved with this oh he was invested
did you
see did you see up to the point where i
think
this was when he was trying to find it
again
when yeah i watched a bit where the it
would dip it would dip
yeah but he tried to find it and then he
reached out and it came to him and it
wrapped around him did you see that yeah
that's crazy yeah the whole thing is mad
that's crazy i saw the bit when the the
arm got bit off
i was i was i'm not gonna lie my
adrenaline was pumping when that that
bit happened
the nature is just too much it's too
much my man said he didn't want to
intervene
i would have yanked that fish or that
shark i would have gripped it
get off her get off get off her
she's my baby get off her listening as
well it's like
i'm very intrigued you know when people
like i don't want to interrupt the
natural order of nature and stuff like
that
but then the more you look at nature
you're like but is there any
natural order to this it's all chaos
yeah as far as what i can see
it's all chaos nothing is supposed to or
not supposed to happen
like so you getting in the way of it is
like is that really
such a bad thing i don't i don't
necessarily know i don't know what trust
i'm trying to say
i know what you're trying to do yeah
it's like just the normality yeah people
have like a real
i think people have a massive stance on
it like you said like when we're talking
about
we cook our food and all this stuff and
we're so disconnected from nature
we're so disconnected from nature that
we can actually truly believe
that if we stop a shark killing octopus
that we're interrupting nature like say
we
like so we're not part of this yeah yeah
you know what i mean yeah yeah like i
said we're not actually a part of this
thing
we're so disconnected that we think
we're a completely different
i don't even know i know what you mean a
completely different creature
so what's going on over here there's
nature and then there's human beings
yeah and they
the natural order of things is for us to
live our own sophisticated lives
and for them to do their like
cannibalistic [ __ ] chaotic [ __ ] over
here and we have nothing to do we have
nothing there's more of them than they
are of us
yeah and just like to think that like
you can
and i understand why someone would think
that but to think that
that i'm thinking about now it's just
like wow that's so peculiar that
we think we're so far from animals that
if we actually stop one animal killing
another we're all of a sudden
interrupting nature
yeah like say we're not like nature we
don't exist we exist in our own universe
we're we are we are clouded and deluded
in that old
completely jaded in the whole thing like
we yeah
yeah it's mad it is mad but yeah it was
an interesting it was very interesting
documentary
it was super super interesting yeah if
anyone sorry to cut you off i was gonna
say if anyone has
any um wildlife documentary
recommendations please
tag it below or comment below oh yeah i
was reading the comments the other day
as well to watch
this doesn't make sense so many people
asked in the comments
what was the name of the david
attenborough thing that i was talking
about
but i said it do i mean
just for you man it's called the hunt
but i i literally said the hunt at least
three times
and they're like oh what was that david
averaging right
rewind it
bro stuff like that is always like come
on
just rewind it i probably just want you
to reply i guess
dave want me to reply they want someone
else someone else
that's my favorite david albert ever um
before i go into fan request
i have a question for you interesting
it's interesting to hear specifically
what your answer would be yeah
okay why uh
or what i just know when you ask me the
question
yeah you'll know when you answer the
question all right say no more let's
just say
all the mandem died so we men
in general when you say mandarin okay
okay okay
okay jesus yeah so let's just say we all
died in a tragic accident yeah
and we all get sent up to heaven yeah
and at the big pearly gates
god's there yeah and he's like cool
flakes in and you're like gang
oh so we all died i thought he said i
thought you meant like you guys died i'm
still alive no you died too oh so well
okay so this is actually no
let's extend it okay not just the mother
everyone you love
jesus all your closest friends and
everyone you love we all died
this is dark it is dark um we all died
and we all got to heaven
and then god only lets you in and he
sends all of us to hell
yeah to suffer yeah you ask him
oh like why did you do that like what
did they do kind of thing and he's like
i don't know and you just kind of like i
don't know i just
just didn't fancy letting them in he's
like they didn't specifically do
anything but
like i just come bothered yeah and he
said and you were like okay
and then sent us all down to hell yeah
would you come and chill and help me no
what kind of stupid question is that
so you chill in heaven all alone and
everyone you know
is in hell you're just going to let us
burn for all the teddy so i should come
and join you and burn for all this honey
i'm just asking if you i'm saying you
should or shouldn't i'm just asking if
you would oh
i answered a question a minute ago no no
of course i would you even contemplate
no
not in the slightest
that's that's the easiest question
you've ever asked me okay what if
what if you literally wouldn't see
another person in heaven that's
different oh
okay now i'm in obviously now we've got
that answer i'm asking a different
question now okay okay
if you if you use just you in heaven
obviously you can do whatever you want
heaven is anything you want it to be but
it's just you
it's you and god that's it hmm
um i probably it will probably be a
longer thought process the same way when
you ask me
would i rather slap my mum or do i go
have to think about it but probably the
same answer because the thought of
burning
alone is enough the thought of burning
for eternity
yeah is something completely different
nah that's a human's problem
fair play interesting thought of burning
for eternity
is a scary concept oh of course bro it's
a scary guy
of course we're all burning we're all
down here i'm upstairs
i know you would i'm upstairs that's why
you know that's why i thought if you
just
ask you oh you make me laugh
of course i'm so selfish
you're so selfish
oh what would you do you'd go to hell
maybe
i'd contemplate it for sure i wouldn't
i've been alone in heaven forever yeah
but that's
that was the second question that's what
i said i'd question i'd contemplate it
but probably the same answer
i'd probably say i'll most likely still
stay in heaven cool but i'd still think
about it yeah but first off the first
distance
okay what about this one then let's say
you have kids and everything okay
hang on let's say you're in this
scenario i'm listening i [ __ ] missed
it
okay so in this one cool so we go back
to the first scenario yeah there are
other people in heaven
okay so it's just a normal heaven life
yeah [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] in heaven yeah but like
all of us are in hell
yeah your kids are in hell jesus
your wife's in hell everyone's you know
your mom and your dad are all in hell
yeah we're burning but you actually
coming down
we still all have to burn but like you
can ease our suffering
like okay i can be the catalyst to
subdue like
not just like well not not the act of
you coming down eases everyone else is
suffering
but you can actually for example if
lucifer wants to rape your kid you can
stop him
okay today do you know what i mean like
you can fend like look you can help us
the same way
you could help us in the jungle if you
just came down with a baseball bat
okay because you can't protect everyone
from everything yeah but you're here
yeah to help us
a little bit yeah yeah yeah okay okay so
you come down to hell and god lends you
a baseball bat yeah it's like fight if
you're gonna go
yeah then go and you've got baseball
back and you're gonna suffer a little
bit too
but when like the devils are coming for
the kids and they're coming from the man
and everybody
you can help us from time to time yeah
your efforts will be well received
yeah if that's the scenario or you can
just
forget we ever existed yeah and just
live
lavish in heaven in that scenario if i'm
coming down to help am i staying there
[Laughter]
you're just gonna let us suffer bro
you're the funniest cat i've met i'm not
going that's certified just then
you're the funniest cat there look go in
that's hilarious i'm not going
that's hilarious that stems back to what
you said in the other episode about
um fending for yourself for 10 years yes
that's the system that you do yes what
you that's what
your dad only cared about grades this is
what he's produced
i hope he's proud because when he gets
sucked down to hell
he's gonna think ra i should have kept
him in south london
if i knew this was gonna be the result
that's hilarious that is jokes
oh my god that's funny that is very
jokes all right let me get my breath
back and i'll do it
she's screaming actually okay go for it
oh [ __ ] you know that's funny boom it's
a long one
to sit tight um
cool big fan from you've probably seen
this i think he dropped it in the
in our one as well but he sent it to me
individually as well
uh big fan from sweden listen listening
since episode 20 i'm currently 16 years
old
basically my situation is weird last
october i like this girl after some time
i noticed she wasn't matching the energy
so i left
at this stage i hadn't even kissed a
girl and i had no game
a bit later i met this girl and we
started talking
after like two weeks she was already
saying love stuff
but as as someone who didn't talk to
girls i just kept it moving
two weeks after that i had lips her
multiple times etc
but i didn't like who
but i didn't like who i was becoming so
i ended it
oh my days said
man tasted a bit of the game i said nice
not for me
these streets were not made for me bro
wow that's funny after a few lipses i
didn't like who i was becoming so i
ended it
jesus let me get my breath back a couple
days later
my brother had an 18th birthday party i
got drunk for the first time
and still can't remember most things
whilst i was drunk
i had a i had called the girl i just
ended things with and had told her to
come over of course shooting
of course she might had a bit of a
whiskey dick oh and he said slide
through
then she came over we went upstairs i
don't recall these things so it's just
from a friend's memory
next thing i remember is
go on next thing i remember is me and
her having sex
i subbed up and just said to her stop i
don't want to do this and fell asleep
wow she didn't have anything to drink
whilst
whilst i was [ __ ] up the next day i
confessed to the first girl that i had
done things with another girl
at the at the time we hadn't talked for
over a month so i took
so i don't know why i apologize fair
enough
she took it harsh so i started to fight
for her after some time we were on good
terms
and during and at the talking stage
when she wasn't [ __ ] out let me start
again after some time we were on good
terms
and at the talking stage when she when
she
from nowhere stopped everything and said
some [ __ ]
ah i hate the way some people type from
nowhere in terms of like out of nowhere
yeah yes
anyway i later found out she met another
guy after a month
we started talking again and for the
next four months we were
really close and almost together then
from nowhere she wanted a break two days
later she
makes out with eight guys from a party i
removed her from my snap
but it was gang with the eight or gang
up my removed from his snap
now the eight okay because you said i
removed them from the snap you're like
gang
that's my girl when the the sloppy tops
with a six man
that's that all over again do you not
think so what
the selena whatever the only fans chick
sucking off six man the basketball team
though i don't remember
you're talking way back now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah anyway yeah i removed her
from snap but it was
hard not to write to her so i did talk
to her
here and there i later removed her from
everything and moved on she texted me
and said she wants to try again but i
said she's not good for me and i can't
trust her
i later found out that she had been with
at least five
guys and also slept with two in her life
i'm assuming so because he said he's
16. yeah yeah yeah so i'm assuming she's
of similar age
unless he's out of [ __ ] cougars um i
now know that while we were almost
together
she had said to her best friend that she
had me around her
little finger i could do anything to me
looking back at it okay this is the
first yeah now yes
cool looking back a couple months later
i would have seen the red flags and left
but at the same time it's really
it really breaks my heart so i'm a bit
scared to trust someone
what do you think i should do just focus
on myself or try again every time i put
myself into something
they break my heart love you guys have a
blessed day
big man there's so much to dissect yeah
so okay let me
let me give you man a run through
because we've laughed and spoken out
off topic throughout the whole thing
donnie's from sweden
i'm 16 years old i liked a girl
he has no game whatsoever he hadn't even
kissed a girl after two weeks
another yacht was saying that oh he
loves that they're talking about love
etc
um didn't work out moved to another
thing two weeks later
lipped a couple times but he ended it
because he didn't like where things were
coming because
he didn't like didn't like who i was he
liked the man he was becoming
he saw the streets and he closed the
door he said yeah right he said now this
is the streets aren't for me yeah
yeah a couple days later 18th birthday
party got drunk
holiday ting went upstairs did a couple
things
hands went mad hands went maverick man
someone went on today
it reminded me it reminds me of when
remember what i don't know if i said on
it i'm definitely set on it
the shoreditch [ __ ] where she sat on it
and you're like get off
get off me she said that nice she sat on
it
[ __ ] she was so useless not even not
sexually
but as a human being like it sounds it
sounds so bad saying out loud but
because we
know yeah the context are she was such a
useless person
anyway um so yeah um
he confessed well he confessed to
sleeping with this other chick to the
first girl
the first girl was like
and now she's trying to get back with
him but she's
his heart's really broken yada yada
should he move
on or should he fight for this hope
basically cool now you missed out loads
in there
so he didn't like who's becoming he
didn't like then he got drunk he got
drunk follow the thing again
person b person b again person b came
round yeah
smash they smashed and then he said stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop
then he tried to get back with
personality then whilst
almost getting back with person a he
finds out all this trash about oh yeah
yeah
yeah and now he's locked off person a
again now he's got no one she's got no
one
and now he's wondering whether to go
back to person a for a third time
he is the def sorry bro you're the
definition of a simp
in my opinion i'm not going to speak for
flakes
but it's okay we've all been there yeah
it's not to be fair we have it's not
the be or end all right where do i start
right
firstly fair play for
trying the streets realizing it wasn't
for you but when you've got
that irish courage you were like yo i
can be in the streets for one night
and the fact that you actually rolled
through
she's a good one props she's a good
[ __ ] host from right turn e10
[Laughter]
bro he was on some brent stuff that's
cool
that's all well and good and then if
you've got a conscience when you sobered
up fair enough again it happens that's
cool
right so you went back to baby girl in
point a
you then found out that she lipped up
eight guys in one party
right how do i feel about this
i don't think i care but then again i've
lived more than him yeah this is i'm
trying to think from a 16 year old's
perspective
if i was 16 i'm locking her off i'm
devastated oh yeah yeah you can't get
out here lips in eight
one party in one party you're are you
the only girl there
that's what i want to know they must
have been playing spin the ball they
must have been playing spin the ball and
you were the only hoe like you had to
lips any guy that bottle landed on
that makes an bro so yeah you just had
your lipsy man
like clearly from then she's not about
it yeah she's not
she wants to be in the streets while you
realize the streets ain't for you
she's keen on she's keen on issues and
she's telling and she's banged five guys
she's telling mutual brethren that oh
i've
and the thing is as well obviously
that's unacceptable from the jump
in her defense the way you're acting i'm
not surprised she feels that way um
she shouldn't be running that kind of
game she's don't okay let me jump to the
end she's a horrible person you need to
lock her after you're toxic and she's
horrible when you need to go
you have to get rid of her but let's
backtrack yeah
yeah acting like a little bit of a [ __ ]
in that let's find the streets
the only [ __ ] part is that like you're
even contemplating going back to her for
a third time
even after she you found out she lips
fights eight dons she's [ __ ] five guys
and she's telling the next bedroom that
you're wrapped around a little finger
and you're contemplating going back
going back big man have some respect
the thing is i know obviously i know
where i come from and i completely agree
but like you said i'm trying to think
like a 16 year old
he's remember he's a virgin oh he's not
a virgin anymore but
that he's not had
any experience he's got no he said he's
got no games
for him i understand so it's it's a
completely different card
it's a complete i'm assuming
this chick that he's with obviously yes
she's talking the chick that he wants to
go back to the first chick chick hey
yes she's toxic but he clearly loves her
i know i mean but that i've been i've
seen red flags you've seen red flags for
me and i've stayed in situations do you
know what i mean
so i understand but there's levels to
these red flags
of course the red flags even at their
worst the red flags were nowhere near
the minimum that what my mind is yeah i
get that
but again i don't know what's hap i
don't know why guanine in sweden
do you know what i mean true sweden
could be a complete
sweden sounds like a vibe i'm not gonna
lie to you i'm not gonna lie to you
there's tings in sweden
she's probably banging because there's
tens instead some of the teams in sweden
that's because the sweden is as white as
you can get yeah
they're they're pure viking white yeah
finland sweden yeah
these are these nordic man are there so
they're just like
there's white but then there's purebred
white with the bluest
blueest device they're perfect they're
just ah swedish hoes are
banging if you like white things
make me raise swedish girls mixed race
swedish girls that's what's going to say
that's because they that's because
they're the first generation of
white as you can get yeah and they their
dads are always as african
as they're congolese as you can possibly
imagine
and the offspring is just beautiful fam
the mixes that come out of there are
swedish chicks banging so yeah to be
fair
this this yeah that's tearing his heart
apart could be absolutely banging he
could
i bet she's bagging she has to be
banging let's just assume i don't even
want to say that because he's 16.
the donnies are banging as well he's
probably banging as well
let me actually this man hit six foot at
like 14 years
that tall [ __ ] oh he's things a
lot so i'm i'm not gonna follow you
sorry
but yeah like ah bro at the end of the
day but just
how do i explain it it just gotta get
rid like
the only way you you can move on from
this is if you take
my words as gospel
and believe that there are going to be
so many other hoes
because these man hearing me say it but
they clearly don't yeah because we
we say that almost every time something
like this comes something like this
always comes up and they all think it's
like
it's do or die or die yeah and this
[ __ ] is basic
launch her man and the thing is the
moment you do launch or the moment you
do
ease off and she sees that you're no
longer simple she sees that you're no
longer giving her the attention or
whatever
she's gonna think why is he not giving
me the [ __ ] attention i used to get
and then she's gonna
she might not come crawling back but it
will do so much for you
do you know what i mean he'll do
something yeah man he's just gonna do
like you don't want to be going down
like okay this is what this is a way
that you can perceive it
imagine so this is how this is exactly
this this is probably
an easy way we in order for us to relate
to you we always have to picture how we
were 16 when we were 16. why don't you
try
imagining looking back at this when
you're 30. very true
very true and how much of a waste man
you're going to feel
imagine being a 30 year old man thinking
back to when you were 16
contemplating dealing with a girl who is
treating you like [ __ ]
he's going to read this next year and
think what the [ __ ] that i just said
do you know what i mean he's going to
look back at this message that he sent
us and be like
why did i even why did i even have to
send that i'm embarrassed i had to send
that
i was going through it and big man i've
said a million times in my time i
haven't fit when i was 16.
we have been been through it been
through bro yeah try and picture how
you'll feel when you're a 29 year old
man looking back looking back
i think it is very embarrassing but
obviously at the time when you're in it
when you're involved in it it's hard to
dissect it it's hard to even
know how to take logically yeah when
you're in there's emotional states you
can't think logically it's hard no logic
comes like reaches you in those in those
moments so it's completely
understandable
but yeah bro like honestly lock her off
she's trash
she is she's she's probably banging oh i
bet she slops as well
i bet she gives the nasty nice lips and
eight man in her shrubs
she must slop she must slops on top
she does the most eight eight man
that's a lot of man i have never i don't
think i believe there's more than three
gal in another has to be orchestrated
you can't coincide any lipstick
they played them in the ball they have
to play spin the ball they were tossing
her around you can't just lips eight men
in one party it doesn't work
it doesn't work imagine being one of the
man
that was dashing around this girl and
then bumping into
you and this girl in the street and just
being like
come on come on brother i just lost yeah
it's trash
like me and amanda had our way at a
party
come on you're arguing at the bus stop
so if you think about it that way boy
and this thing as well is like where are
you in this pecking order
because obviously these men that are
tossing are about
think she's here and then she looks at
you and thinks you're here the thing is
the thing is context though because he
said
it was an 18th birthday party so i'm
assuming
maybe the guy she was lips in were older
guys so she was just gassed off the age
difference and uh do you know what i
mean
i never still i know but i i know but
within a lot of
not a lot of females i'm assuming at
that age maybe females are gassed off
older yeah so i think she was just
taking advantage of the situation which
is
it has its own pros and cons do you know
what i mean yeah so
take an advantage you the novelty wins
out like three max yeah yeah eight
minutes eight is holding yeah
i still can't wrap my head around it
eight man is a lot eight man is a lot
yeah bro that needs to get locked and
then she's disrespecting you
on top of that wrapped around right
finger nah i could do all what i went
back to on my finger
first the first day you heard that you
should have been like okay now i know
she doesn't raise me she doesn't rate me
i need to stop being a simp
and i need to just move on with my life
she literally doesn't rate me
as a human being as a man she doesn't
rape me maybe a man is a human as a
human
as a liberal organism she doesn't ring
me just dash her
it's fine it's literally fine to
dashboard i think this is well it
literally doesn't mean anything it
doesn't just because she
she clearly doesn't care about you
enough so you don't need to warrant her
feelings when you dash
yeah yeah yeah you just dash just dash
it bro it's minor
and just be like cool you just the
coolest thing you can do is just
approach her on a very humble
don't even say how much it hurt when you
said this and all this stuff
just say black you know what yeah it's
absolutely fine however you feel about
me however you feel about me
i don't need that level of toxic [ __ ] in
my life so like we're done here
and that's fine like it's cool i'm not
angry you don't need to be angry
you don't rape me and that's absolutely
fine not everyone's going to rate me
and just bless or you can go back to
chick b
yeah you can go back to chubby some
seriously cause she's clearly down
you need to stop all this uh i'm not
liking the person i'm becoming talk
this is this is part of life b this is
it's well and truly part i gotta get
some experiences you have to get some
experience you're gonna go through like
a whole phase per se you're gonna go for
a phase where you're probably gonna get
your heart broken
there's so many phases you're gonna go
through life and you need to just
embrace them and just take it by the
balls and just go with it man it's not
even
it's not ideal it's not it's it's not
that deep man and it's when you say ah
man said man said i'm not liking the
person i'm coming if my lips are on the
third time i was like i don't think i
like the guy i'm coming
who is this guy we need to stop we need
to stop lips lipson you know
not even banging it's not even like you
just done a threesome like
yeah lancaster and said i don't think
this can continue
i'm not this kind of dark human being
this isn't me this isn't me
this it has to be you now yeah always
been you know now especially since you
build her when you were drunk because
they come through
actually as she came through sober
sober and you spanked it
ah you have no idea how much sauce you
have clearly
also also also
this is good perspective as well
don't be a hypocrite my g because think
about it
he's out here upset
about girl a all the trash he's doing
he's gone to chick b dana ting locked
her
then belder when he wants her [ __ ] her
locked her again
you're just as bad as go hey cause man
you're just as bad
man you don't know it but you're already
in the streets
yeah you don't know it already but
you're already in the streets you're on
the streets unbeknownst because
you've not taken charge of the situation
and the fact that you've
you've used your emotion from chick a
to go to chick b once you've realized
chick b isn't what you want
you've still penetrated her you still
bust your nut and then you've locked it
you got what you wanted
you got what you wanted at dashter you
said the way she got what she wanted
chick
got what she wanted from you and she
doesn't need you anymore that's why she
said she's got it
yeah exactly and probably got some
b-rats around little fingers about
literally literally just about to say
you got chick b
you rapped but you've basically told us
you've got chickpea wrapper on your face
you wanted a chick while you were drunk
and she was sober she came through and
you smashed
you're 16 cubs i wasn't doing that
i wasn't doing that at 16. i was begging
hoes at 16. i
was hands and
i guess i guess we've answered your
question you know what you need to do
you need to lock up chick a
you need to also not be a hypocrite as
james suggested and just
live your true life man just just know
holes bar do what you need to do because
yeah man
life waits for no one man this is always
been alone exactly
oh you need your space enjoy being alone
because it's not going to last long
oh trust me it's not going to last long
these hoes
it's literally not um have we got them
in the middle is that good
have we gotten them either or no i think
i've got one
well it's not enough it's not am i the
answer but it's a dilemma
okay so this is annoying he knows who he
is
this is very annoying i think i told you
this before oh come on
so um obviously as you know or
as you may or may not know when you when
you guys have found dms obviously
it will go into a request like dm us
personally not in on our shits and gigs
when our personal ones
it will obviously go into our requested
and if we reply and we reply when we
want to reply kind of thing because
obviously we're busy people
um so the guys that do follow me there
was there was a day where i was wearing
a suit
and guy messaged me saying oh bro
where's the suit from it's cold
and i replied to him a few days later
because i was probably dinner with ceo
ever and he was like thanks bro
whilst i've got you man sent three pages
of dilemmas
which mean whilst i've got you i was
like
it's sweetened me but anyway anyway
thanks bro while i got you i'm gonna
slip you a dilemma
about a year ago i had one i had a one
night stand with a girl from
my uni oh i've actually read this i
remember it now it's jokes
so about a year ago i had one night i
had one [ __ ] i can't speak
about a year ago i had one night stand
with a girl from uni
after it after it was done she kept my
shirt
he put in brackets polo he was a polo
shirt um
i asked for it back over socials but
every time i saw her in real life
in the eating area or a party i never
felt like asking
when because we never talked about after
hooking up which is fine
blah blah and it didn't i didn't really
want to bring it up again because it was
awkward
fast forward to modern day she's dating
someone new now i know this guy
we're not best friends but he's a cool
dude i get along with him he's in the
same music class but he literally wrote
blah blah blah
now we're now in the same drama school
meaning social distancing is
low-key impossible one day i'm chilling
and i see him wearing my shirt
dread now i assume that he did this he
did that thing of staying at your ting's
place
and pop him in as some popping on some
clean clothes and not questioning it
plus it's been a year and this girl was
around the block
in quotes a sket
so she probably doesn't remember now
obviously i want the shirt back
but that's not the only reason i'll be
honest i piped her in that shirt and i
bust on it
i assume slash i hope she washed it
we're not super close friends but as a
man i respect i don't think i
it's right for me not to say anything
and all my friends suggest
to start violating him in public on some
ghetto [ __ ] what should i do
this is gone this has gone on a spiral
because
yeah this is kind of a spider i was
really with him the whole time
then my friend said violate him
we're talking about hold up all right
let me recap
oh my dad okay recap is he was seeing a
thing
um he had a one-night stand with the
girl he left his polo shirt at
this girl's yard um fast forward a year
later she's or fast forward
didn't say what time frame fast forward
anyway she's now dating someone else
but the breath she's dating is in the
same drama class as him
um but he knows that this chick was a
skep
around the time he [ __ ] her and
he's now seen the new bruh wearing his
shirt
basically saying what should i do should
i violate him or edc yeah
that is kind of a mother also actually
but um
um bro literally
in my opinion it's a shirt
for one for one two why would you
violate him
what under what i wonder what princess
yeah
why what's he done he's unbeknownst to
this situation bro he's seen a clean
shirt and he's put it on
why is what violated to be fair to be
fair when he said
let me get this here he said one day i'm
chilling and i'll see myself
uh now i assume that he didn't he did a
thing of staying at yours
at your thing's place i'm popping on a
clean club clean pair of clothes and not
questioning it
that's a big red flag for me oh i was
going to get to that as well
okay all right cool who does that
who does that who puts on another man's
clothes
at your goals at your girl's yard and
just doesn't say [ __ ]
to be fair though actually to be fair
now i'm saying that loud we have no idea
what he said
she could have said it's my dad it's my
brother's true true true true true true
i bought it for an x and never gave it
to him like you yeah
we have no content that's very true i
remember so
this is funny i remember i was thinking
about as soon as he said that i saw my
mom wearing my shirt
i remember when i first started dating
one of my ex-girlfriends years ago
i was at her house one time and she
did the biggest [ __ ] up i was this close
to leaving her
this close on the spot i think early
days i remember
she literally turned to me we've been
seeing each other for a couple months
and i was in her room and she to me and
she was like oh you left your boxes here
the other day
and i remember thinking why she know i
don't think she said the other day
but she said oh i found a pair of your
boxers
and she dashed them to me and they were
not my [ __ ] boxers brother
i was this close
to walking out with that explanation
without without you saying anything or
like just dipping or what
i would have said they're not my boxers
okay i said immediate as soon as they
hit the bed i was like then i'm on boxes
and i stared at her straight face
i wasn't even angry what happens now
yeah
where did we go from here and then the
only i think the only reason i left it
was because like
she was so like um how to explain it
she was so straight on the back of like
okay cool they're my ex-boyfriend's
boxers
without like there was no point where
she was like
yeah she was like ass [ __ ] like she was
embarrassed that she said it to me yeah
but she was so like straight to the
uh they're like probably my experience
they're my ex-boyfriend's voices like
and i already knew that she just got out
with like a very long relationship with
her
ex-boyfriend and stuff like that it like
it genuinely didn't bother me that much
but like if if she was someone who had
who i knew she
hadn't had like a long-time boyfriend
give me next mouse boxes
i would have gone i would have run out
the door
ran out the door as a
i don't know that's it's probably it's
probably shows how true her statement
was then
because if i'm true in a sense that it
was probably ex-boyfriend's
boxes oh because if roles were reversed
and i found
in my yard i found a pair of frenchies
and
and you know you've had hoes up in the
yard i'm framing the frenchies in a bin
if you ask me back from the french's i
don't know where they are you took them
off that's your problem
you misplaced them 100 i don't i would
never have the bravado to be like oh by
the way
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly there's
i'm assuming she had enough common sense
that if she had man up in the yard
she wouldn't have just been so blase
about oh here's your boxes your boxes by
the way
so but boy there's no way
a girl can offer me man's clothes under
any pretense i mean
and not only the only the only time i
would wear it
is if like something drastically bad
happened to the clothes i had
and i had to wear it to get home oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then once i get home
is done yeah yeah i'm not walking around
campus in this
shirt brav no that's that's
disrespectful
yeah but in terms of like that's his own
issue in terms of this violation thing
but
he doesn't want to fight he said he's
friends yeah boy your boys are
your waist your boys are weird man
this is for wearing a shirt this is down
the list he said fast forward to modern
day she's now dating some of her likes
this is time why oh so this is wait so
she's not even dating the same guy
anymore
no no no no the prayer she's dating is
the bread with the shirt oh sorry i
thought you meant she's now dating
someone after the show
no no no no no and we're still looking
to violate you man
i'm not gonna lose it no no yeah
yeah sorry he said it's been like a year
now right it's been so after a year
you're going to then try to violate that
ah say what like also bravado saying ah
smash you're going you're wearing my
gums
shut your mouth don't entertain tell
your boys
don't entertain that for a second
because that is the pussiest thing
ever i've ever heard ever it's not it's
it's that's the most beta move it's gone
the the whole thing is
i didn't have to explain it yeah bro
it's such a weird it was it was like a
very like oh that's awkward
so like uh it was juicy awkwardness it
was juicy awkward but now it's just like
it's weird we're gonna try and violate
my man
under what presents and you said he was
cool as well it was cool and you said
music class clinging triangles and that
boy do you not think it's weird speaking
of his thingy do you not think it's
weird that
he the only reason why he's
outlandishly called a rasquet is because
he's been inconvenienced
in the sense of it by some next man as
well you just said it was a one-night
stand
so why you need to like because her name
is is
oh she's a scare you've you had a
oneness down with her
so if if you got your shirt and
everything was fine
then she's just like a trooper and she's
cool
because you haven't got your shirt back
like it's such a shirt it's done like
i'm sorry the shirts
yeah i'm not getting that even if i got
the shirt back i'm not wearing it
do you know what i mean one night stand
that comes with the territory it comes
with the tape everyone that's standing
you leave your gums in the yard it's
done it's done
it's done you've just lost your gums
that's the price you paid for
[ __ ] someone with one night stand
your gums are gone it's gone
you should have took it yeah
yeah bro that's got weird man here's
weird
i'm not a fan of that it got very weird
but yeah
anyway you um you should not
not not not entertain what your boys are
saying about violating my man because
he's wearing the shirt it makes no sense
um you should move on you should be a
[ __ ] adult move on
yeah be an upstanding gentleman you got
your nut
at the end of the day and you've lost a
shirt that's your fault that's the thing
man it's like the same thing what we
said about earlier like our fast forward
like
how would a how would a 29 30 year old
man think about the situation with the
guy before yeah like
in this situation i was this is like not
that i haven't
had to explain it without sounding like
i've got an ego
i never find myself in petty situations
like that but
he's younger than me yeah you've never
had life experience i've had life
experience yeah
but in those moments what i would like
to do if i could is think
what would the coolest guy possible do
in this situation
what would the coolest dude do in this
situation
violating my man on instagram or twitter
whatever you're going to do on the
socials
is definitely the least cool thing you
could possibly do
chasing a shirt that you lost from a nut
a year ago
also not cool bro the coolest thing you
could do is forget about the shirt
replace it or don't and just live your
life
keep getting your nuts keep losing or
not losing your shirts
like that's the cool [ __ ] to do like
chasing the whole situation's done yeah
it's so in the past it's so irrelevant
when he lost his shirt we just started
this podcast
context and here we are here we are
what's going on
why are we still chasing the shirt this
shirt's done
ah because it was a polo so i've been
had paulo's jeep
it could have been valencia shoes but
bro it's done
it's done anyway that's your answer mum
yeah i'm not too impressed with that one
i'm afraid bro
i was really cool with it up until the
like three quarters in
yeah and i was like you sound a little
bit bitter i'm not gonna lie
do you sound better maybe she likes it
yeah maybe you like this chick
maybe it wasn't a one-night stand yeah
it wasn't one night i think you tried to
play mr cool guys with the one night
standing and yeah you sound like you've
got a bit of an emotional attachment to
this
because if it was a one-night random you
wouldn't need you wouldn't feel the need
to call a rescuer
if it was a one-night stand it's a
wonderland you know when i was in uni do
you think i knew who or who wasn't
scared
i got my nuts and i got one more life i
don't know what she did from here
so i mean i don't know who she's dating
yeah i don't know whose shirt is what
yeah i don't know none of these tips
could have been wearing my shirts every
wednesday i don't know don't know what i
don't
know
i put my nut and i left if it was a one
night stunting i don't know about all of
this stuff
unless i've got feelings for this hoe
then i know who she's dating
then i know who's wearing my gums you
must have feelings for her but
or it's a small circle of people that
you always going to bump into the blood
yeah because you said you're
in the same drama class as her new man
so
well she cleaned out skate anymore she's
got a boyfriend in it yeah that's the
team as well bruh she's got i'm actually
trying to settle down she's trying to
escape
calling us trying to get some [ __ ] that
doesn't even matter to her anymore yeah
fam
yeah bro it's a bit like i don't know
man i'm not on your side with this one
at all yeah sorry bro we're not on your
side on this one be cool
just be a caller human being bro
everyone knows a cool dude they do
you're not acting cool bro and your
friends are adding the least cool
speaks volumes g shall we violate man on
the socials
it makes no sense to me what's the end
game here
so he feels okay cool let's say we take
the route let's say we said
big man definitely violate him on the
social you violate him on the socials
say whatever you want to say about him
what do we do from here
how do we sleep at night what have we
done if you violate him he's more likely
not going to give you a share back
a burden shirt and that's what standard
i'm recording myself cutting it up and
then sending you that i'm recording
myself
gagging my girl with your shirt well i
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her
that's what i'm doing and now where did
we go from because i'm seeing you at
drama class on thursday yeah and then
i'm gonna wipe my ass
with your shirt afterwards we're gonna
do that and you're gonna see it in your
debt on your desk the next day
then where do we go so what have we
achieved what have we really achieved
we've not achieved anything people are
funny humans are funny
yeah just move on with yeah this wasn't
am i the [ __ ] big man
yeah well yeah that would be you that
should be it'll be more your friends
yeah thank you don't be influenced
you've got lame friends but don't be
influenced by that yeah that's baby chat
that is
weird anyway shall we wrap it up
yazerski
calm see y'all soon